the European Parliament and I'm speaking
of course about the backlash against
women's rights and not only in European
Union but worldwide and this committee
meeting is timely because we see that
this rolling back on women's rights is a
global phenomenon as I said and we as
committee and the European Parliament
has shown it several times
that we treat attack on women's rights
wherever they are whether they're in
Poland in Afghanistan in Iran wherever
there are as an attack on human rights
and
we see it also as a broader
picture of the rise of extremes
a rise of the groups which are using
which were well organized and using the
resources to undermine the fundamental
human rights
including women's rights because as
Madeleine Albright famously sentence
says women's rights which is obvious for
us of course are human rights and
this hearing was provoked by the
situation in Poland where the running
government and the institutions under
control of the ruling government
has made the situation where Polish
women have less rights than Poland
when they had in 2004 where Poland was
entering European union and this is due
to the series of
facts which we'll be probably discussing
at this committee meeting but it has led
to the situation where at the end of the
day Polish women cannot exercise the
same rights as women in other member
states and that's why our committee is
calling constantly for Country acting
the pushback against pushback on women's
rights I would say and this is why one
of our fundamental
goals and the second goal for that and
the remedy is a constant call for
standardization on women's rights not
only on sexual and reproductive and
health and rights but also on other
rights of women in European Union
and we will be hearing today our experts
our distinguished guests which I I try
to to create a
waiting atmosphere for before I
introduce our guests but we will be
speaking about
the effect of the legislation which is
introduced in Poland and other countries
which has dramatic consequences just few
weeks ago colleagues I want to remind
you we were discussing the case of
Isabella from strina on special hearing
one of the six confirmed victims of the
barbaric legislation introduced in
Poland or the de facto ban on abortion
and this
this legislation has already it's real
victims as those are women who are dying
because of that and those are also women
who are being sentenced uh because of
helping other women or being brave
enough
of helping other women and what I hope
from this house and this committee today
is that we will say it clear that we
want to stop criminalizing Polish women
we want to stop criminalizing people
helping other people in access to their
fundamental rights that we want
every woman wherever she lives to have
access to fundamental rights and this is
the message we as European Parliament we
are obliged to send
and I hope we will be sending today and
I will be hearing this from our
colleagues because as I said our
position as a committee is clear on that
we voted that we Dubai debated that we
made the decisions and
with this without further delay let me
go into presentations of four
distinguished guests we have they were
they're coming from different countries
but they will be speaking about
the topic which I said before backlash
on women's rights and the first of them
is my compatriot I have a friend of mine
a woman which I admire
of her work and I have honored to work
with Justina for some time she's a human
rights Defender a real hero in Poland a
founder of the website women on the net
it's a Polish first online Forum helping
women seeking safe abortions you can
imagine how Brave it is to
lamps outside and do it in a country
where you can be persecuted for this
kind of action and actually this is a
case of istena as you all know she was
sentenced and she will be speaking about
that she currently works for the
excellent abortion Dream Team
organization which is a grouse route
initiative with the goal of improving
Direct in and in immediate assistance to
women who needs abortion and in as I
said in March you still have a dream
scar was found guilty of facilitating
abortion and sentence sentence for
providing abortion pills to a woman in
an abusive relationship who had begged
for help could not find this help and
reduce the nine news then I helped her
the woman was
[Music]
the night
for for help and there was Justina who
helped her and afterwards sentence so
it's our honor and privilege to host you
Stena today
and we want to hear your story and your
address to this Parliament and I can
promise you whenever anything happens
which undermines women's rights I want
to assure you that we will never walk
alone
we will always be with you there thank
you very much
thank you for such warm introduction uh
yes my name is
and I've been helping in abortions for
16 years
more than a month ago I was exactly on
March 14 I was sentenced Guilty by a
Polish court for helping in abortion I
am one of the person who is answering
calls and abortional borders helpline
which is operating since December 2019
every day from 8 to 12 20 8 P.M to 8 P.M
you can call a number
222922-597 and get practical information
about how to I don't understand there is
something wrong with the interpretation
and they're asking me
my mic was not off
I think it I think it would help if the
laptop could be moved away from the
microphone
could the laptop be moved away from the
let's try with this okay can you switch
it off
speak to this one this one is better
okay thank you does it work thank you
very much okay thank you interpreters
for your work thank you yes
so once again I am the person who is
helping an abortion for 16 years uh one
a month ago on March 14 I was sentenced
Guilty by a police court for helping
abortion I am the one of the person who
is answering calls and abortion about
borders helpline
which operates from uh December 2019
every day from eight to eight you can
call a number
222922-597 and get a very practical
support how to order the pills what is
happening during taking the pills and to
which countries you can travel to get
the surgical abortion which suggests
people to use safe pills to order them
from saves Source we advise people how
to prepare to abortion and we provide
again very practical information
in this matter
signs the verdict since the verdict of
the Constitutional tribunal abortion
about borders has helped over 100
000 people from Poland to access an
abortion in a foreign in a total in
average it is uh 107 abortions per day
as a part of abortional borders we have
to organize an abortion in foreign
clinics and we pay for the procedure we
pay for their travel and we pay for the
hotels
from the verdict of the Constitutional
tribunal over 2 000 people had a
surgical abortion in foreign clinics
with our support we spent for abortion
almost a half million euro
women travel from Poland to Netherlands
Belgium England France Germany Czech
Republic or Austria we and they are
surprised how kindly and decently they
have been treated in those windows
clinics many of them had previously
tried to get abortion in a Polish
hospitals but gave up they couldn't
stand an unpredictability anymore will
they do it
they the condensation of Polish doctors
being sent from hospital to hospital
they couldn't stand the doctors hiding
behind the concerns clothes or simply
paying uh playing for the time so they
for them it's too late to perform an
abortion since the Constitutional
tribunal verdict we have been receiving
calls from a people who are already in
hospitals more than
um than more often they feel that for a
Polish doctors a threatened or pregnant
with the fetal abnormalities is more
than more it's more important than the
life or well-being of the woman after
the death of Isa from Shina fear
increased not only in patients but also
in US
when we learned of other women in a
situation of similar that Isa was we
wonder will we be able to help her on
time should we advise her to leave the
hospital in order to save life saved her
life
will it be responsible and safe to put
her on a plane or maybe we should risk a
criminal charges and send her abortion
pills to a hospital to say her life
all of that is happening because the
Polish gynecologist choose to be cowards
at the beginning of 2020 Anya the person
who I sent the pills was almost 12
weekly pregnant and contact abortion
Without Borders
on the phone she said that her partner
was controlling her email and the phone
she wrote in emails that she would do
something to herself if she failed to
terminate the pregnancy
I sent her my own abortion pills but she
never used them because her partner
called the police
police took the pills and questioned her
that's how my case started a month ago I
have heard the conviction a conviction
and the judge who ruled them in my case
while justifying the sentence referred
to the rule of law
underlining that every citizen in Poland
must respect the law it was quite absurd
in a situation when when I hear these
words from the judge who was nominated
by the general prosecutor who is the
same person and the ministry of Justice
I was sentenced to eight months of uh
controlled uh Social Service
30 hours per month the day after the
verdict the media reported that my judge
got a quite big promotion to the court
of appeal on the day she sentenced me I
became convicted that in this fight with
the Polish system I had no chance for
the justice besides not only me but also
Anya the woman who I send the pills she
didn't have any chance either
a week ago Anya gave an interview to
Magdalena for the Polish portal
occopress and told her part of the story
uh it the story it's a story about
loneliness and the trauma of being an
unwanted pregnancy the president
discomfort of uncontrolled by omitting
during the pregnancy it's also a story
about systemic violence medical stuff
ignorance
the cruelty of the Polish anti-abortion
law and it's very and it's very narrow
interpretation it's a story of escaping
from the hospital
to be able to save life
before Anya turned to ask for help she
was in a Polish Hospital
she spent there over a week where it was
against her will
she was decorated and starved having
having not eaten for three weeks
she environment constantly several times
a day
she told the doctors at the hospital
that she couldn't stand anymore
that she was so afraid about her life
in the medical records in the nutrition
dance status column the doctor entered
wasting and referred her to psychiatric
consultation
everyone saw her State she was in but no
one asked her if she want to be pregnant
one of the doctors told Anya that if she
didn't start eating
she will be put on a parental nutrition
and spend the rest of her pregnancy in
the hospital
the story of Anya is a story of what has
happened when there is no access to
abortion pills and how to end the
pregnancy without the using of the
method of our grand grandmothers in the
interview Anya says after the police
took my abortion pills the last chance
of a safe abortion has ended for me
after returning home from the police
station when I got home I went to a
toilet
and at first I have in my own hands
I was trying to delayed the cervix
I have heard before from that Midwife
sometimes use this action to speed up
the labor and I just wanted to induce
the miscarriage in that way I started to
bleed
that what I did or I thought I was doing
was I to put the Foley Carteret and
inside the cervix
thick blood came out and I waited
contractions but they never came
I wore this cutter air for days many
days
when it felt out I placed it back into
the cervix and again and again
I did it alone in the silence and I felt
like an animal hunted animal
and I was paralyzed with a fear
all the Higgin parts and other products
I throw it away in a garbage bin in the
neighborhood so I would not leave them
and I would not leave leave any traces
in particular time I found out how
untrue the saying is
that the human dignity is inherent and
cannot be taken away
a few days after Anya started viominting
blood she was flooded with aminoing
fluid
Anya was afraid to go to go to the
hospital because she was worried that
the doctors would try to save the
pregnancy not her
when it got truly awful she went to the
emergency
diagnosed sepsis
doctor cleaned the uterus gave her
antibiotics Anna slept for three days
I sent her these pills
a safe kid
for medical abortion
which is recommended by who
with these pills
you can terminate pregnancy or with your
own without having a contact with a
doctor
it's safe
and its Effectiveness is 98 percent
chance for a safe abortion
but the gents was taken from away from
her
as a consequence
Anya had to use this
the method of our grand
mothers the cutter
and lead to infection and sepsis
to finally be rescued I'm so sorry this
is so much emotional for me
unfortunately she was survived
but she have to stay we and we have to
say the clouds she escaped death
she could be next either from China and
agnies
she was saved by a fact
that she was rushed from a hospital in
time and the doctor noticed that that
she's in a threat to her life
both of us
didn't have chance to adjust this in a
court
when sentencing me the court decided
that saving Anya's life was socially
harmful
the court decided that giving someone a
chance
to has to have a safe abortion is
unlawful
and the law should always be more
important than somebody's life and
health
many times after the verdict I ask
myself if I regret the abortion I don't
if I regret my decision and I don't I
regret that I didn't know that Anya was
going to use the Cuttery that she didn't
have another chance
for a safe abortion that she had to play
with her life
to free herself from unwanted pregnancy
I regret that she was alone
many times I have heard the question how
can
we abortion activists from Poland can be
supported
we will be completely honest with you
abortioned outboarders needs money for
paying for abortions in foreign clinics
we need more initiatives like Belgium
equality Minister Sarah Schlitz from the
or French the French government
this is the real support for the people
with pregnancies with fetal
abnormalities in the second and third
trimester
thanks to that
that they have a safe abortion
Netherlands Belgium and France or France
these treatment treatment are most
expensive what else you can do
Poland must change the abortion law and
stop criminalizing people which help in
abortions
and for the pressure from you is is
needed don't be afraid to put this
pressure on
you can save somebody's life
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
well
it's very really difficult to continue
after these words as you can imagine
it was really moving just enough
thank you very much for your destiny
testimony and you can imagine we have
heard a lot in this committee during our
years of work
but this is one of the most moving
interventions I've ever heard and it
shows the series of the matter we are
dealing with and it's one of the
probably thousands of testimonies of
women who we could show it this
committee so thank you very much and uh
the next time we meet I hope you will be
uh
we clean out of the accusations and and
you'll be free
once again thank you very much Christina
you're a real hero thank you for the
invitation it's all the time uh I'm so
grateful for those kind of invitations
and telling you how the abortion reality
in Poland looks like
thank you we continue with the second
intervention from Poland
and we will here to Dr ashbeta Coral
truck who is also
an activist
but as she is also associate professor
at the University of Warsaw in Poland
and
University in Sweden she also publishes
on the social movements the politics of
reproduction and the backlash against
so-called gender
uh and I had honored to work with
ashbeta on many occasions but she
recently also is an actress
taking her role in the theater in one of
the the stop now utopian
theater
Place radio Maria which shows Poland
without religious mixture of state and
church so it's a very interesting
virtual play which I recommend to you
but I will give the floor now to El beta
who will speak about her experience
expertise as a professor on the issue of
the backlash she will Re remote she will
be connected remotely with us I don't
know whether from Poland or Sweden we
find out but there she is as beta
Carlton
thank you very much for the invitation
can you hear me well
um welcome to the European Parliament
thank you for the invitation to this
hearing and for the opportunity to speak
about one of the most pressing issues
for democracy
I've been studying uh campaigns against
women's rights against gender equality
lgbtq rights for over a decade now
and uh I would like to show with share
with you
um three key points first of all the
opposition to abortion rights
Reproductive Rights women's rights is
part and parcel of the process of the
democratization it's not a side issue is
not something that we should treat
separately is about democracy
second point there are two main Pathways
to the democratization which are
inscribed in anti-gender campaigns
these are politics of knowledge and
political violence and I will come back
to that
and third point is that both of those
issues knowledge and violence
are well within the purview of European
Parliament and also European commission
and there is need to do more
so to my first point
um the attacks on abortion rights
Reproductive Rights lgbtq rights are
often presented as a matter of religious
views about tradition about difference
in opinions and the people who are
behind anti-gender campaigns often claim
that they want to save democracy that
they do it
in the name of the people I think that
Houston Ave Virginia's story showed us
very well what are the costs for the
people of this kind of politics
an available research shows us very
clearly that they speak in the name of a
marginal minority because a vast
majority of European citizens want more
gender equality want more freedom and
not less and more importantly the
anti-gender activists and right-wing
politicians who support them undermine
democracy in its two basic tenets first
of all they challenge the stability of
democratic institutions both in terms of
for example independent judiciary
and the case of Justina shows it very
well how it works and of course
independent University in Academia as
well
I'm these people Challenge and oppose
Core Democratic Values such as equality
pluralism solidarity without those we
simply don't have democracy
so how it is done in practice there are
two important ways or key ways to
Pathways to de-democratizations the
democratization and the struggle around
knowledge production and expertise has
become one of the key battlefields for
the anti-gender campaigners
anti-gender actors use institutions
invested in knowledge product production
such as universities think tanks State
institutions to promote what they call
alternative truths about identity
sexuality family reproduction but these
truths are not rooted in research or
open debate but are rooted in religious
beliefs and this is done a series
through a series of strategies which
include targeting critical uh inequality
studies such as gender studies but also
critical race studies and also specific
Scholars those who work on equality
those who work under productive rise
rights those who work on racism and not
just in countries such as Hungary where
gender Studies have been banned or in
Poland
but also my Swedish colleagues are
increasingly vocal about personal
threats that they received and the
representative of the Swedish Democratic
party went on record saying that gender
and critical race studies should be
controlled by politicians because they
are ideological
another strategy is to facilitate
changes in the domain of knowledge
production changing curricula
withdrawing financial support changing
regulations of professional advancement
and this is done also along
promoting and producing fake knowledge
about gender women's rights but also
climate rights and other pressing issues
so what is happening is the
contamination of language of Human
Rights so the goal is to stop talking
about women women their experience as
Houston I just did they want to talk us
about
um abstract life or physicists as the
minority group
and what accompany this is the
devaluation of scientific expertise that
bodies such as European Parliament rely
on to produce police policy Solutions
another element of this Matrix is
violence and the growing amount of
evidence shows that anti-gender
campaigns contribute to the rise of
political violence both discourses and
physical as well as judicial violence as
in the case of Poland one of the key
strategies of the anti-gender movements
is to vilify feminists lgbtq people
trans people and their allies
these groups are demonized as perverts
they are portrayed as enemies of the
people as part of global Elites which of
course goes in hand in hand with
vilification and demonization of
European Union right as colonizing Force
hence gender is presented as Ebola from
Brussels dangerous contagious form of
ideological imposition
so we know this mechanism very well from
history
vilification of minority groups leads to
victim perpetrator reversal and then it
justifies violence as rightful
self-defense
and in recent years we have witnessed uh
an increased number of smear campaigns
epistemic violence against gender
equality Advocates and also politicians
and also in the European Parliament and
finally also Street violence
uh the attack on participants of the
pride March in 2019 in my hometown by
stock was not an isolated event
it was not side effect
it was a consequence of long-term
campaign against sexual minorities which
was orchestrated by politicians
religious representatives and Civil
Society actors in the early 2000s the
International Community of Scholars
concerned with violent extremism as well
as Security Experts were focused mainly
on islamist groups but today there is a
growing recognition that in most
countries right-wing extremists should
be considered a much bigger threat
right-wing organizations and networks
espouse nativism and nationalism but
also misogyny homophobia racism and
anti-semitism
and they frequently embrace
strategies of violence they disabled
Democratic process as shown by Mason
young blood in the United States over
the last decade the far-right movement
was responsible for 73 of all extremist
murders in the country and in 2018 the
statistic Rose to 98 percent
so my final point is that both violence
and attacks on Academia are crucial to
democracy because they block conditions
for free critically informed and
violence-free participation in
democratic practices and contribution to
public debates
we want to save democracy we better
start now thank you
thank you very much
thank you very much beata thank you very
much Professor for your intervention and
we continue with two more interventions
so far is extremely interesting so I
look forward for Regina Marquez
clinical psychologist who is with us the
teacher and a member of the national
Secretariat of the movie mental
democratico de mujeres women's
Democratic movement of Portugal If I say
it right Miss Marquez will speak on the
advances and Retreats in women's rights
from equality in law to equality in life
a very interesting topic so you have
seven minutes for for that the floor is
yours thank you for being with us
first of all let me thank the Femme
committee
for the invitation
and say good afternoon to you Mr
chairman
and the other members of the panel who
are here with me
I'd also like to say hello to all of the
participants and thank the interpreters
as well since I'm now able to speak in
my own language
today in Portugal
it's the anniversary of the Carnation
Revolution
uh struggle that's to say the
achievements we've had in terms of
women's rights one needs to remember
were born from a democratic revolution
in our country it's a holiday today in
Portugal
but
this work we're doing here is so
important that I came along
let me start by expressing solidarity
with with women of Poland and their
fight for the right to abortion I also
wanted to deal with the question of
abortion in Portugal it was a tremendous
achievement by women
and I wanted to say that it took years
to gain this right we needed two
referendums
and it was finally granted in 2007.
it was an intense struggle by women
there were various movements involved
including mine the pub the parliament
got involved as well and eventually
put forward and propagated the law which
allowed
women in Portugal to have a right to
choose and I would like to stress that
for us this right for abortion it was an
achievement in terms of civilization
it's not just a question of women's
rights it's a question of giving women
the ability to decide over their lives
particularly when
their life is something
which is causing them difficulties so
certain pregnancies can do various
reasons for this uh it could have been
caused by rape the health of the mother
the health of the baby
and economic reasons as well can lead to
a woman needing to Avail herself of the
possibilities of abortion for years
there were Backstreet abortions in
Portugal many women died many children
died and we believe that
the battle is one worth fighting and
we'd like to encourage the women of
Poland to keep going to keep fighting
and they can count on the support of
women throughout Europe
but
we're also seeing a backlash in this
battle there has been legislation
adopted in the United States
and in countries of course such as
Poland
but this backlash
isn't something that just affects the
women in Poland or women in the United
States all of this is going to have an
impact on all of our lives
even
the lives
are the right wing that are taking up
their positions on this in various parts
of the EU and I wanted to tell you that
official reports
demonstrate that after our
law came through undesired unwanted
pregnancies have fallen and that the the
idea was that women would
get abortion after abortion that was the
argument the anti-abortion people used
that's not right not proved to be
correct so the figures show that having
the possibility to
have a safe abortion in health centers
or hospitals with doctors attending
all the statistics prove that it was a
tremendous achievement and that it's
vitally important for reducing
child mortality maternal mortality and
this right of women now over their own
bodies is vitally important we're
continuing the fight on
sexual reproductive rights in Portugal
we want
that
we this is now doctors and nurses are
using this right to object for reasons
of conscience
and we are fighting against the closing
down of health and reproductive sexual
reproductive Health Centers
because
various public services in Portugal
are allowing this use of the objection
for reasons of conscience and having
women being seen by lots of doctors
before she's allowed to have an abortion
that's something that's causing curse
concern because it's in line with issues
that have already been raised this
afternoon I think everyone it sounds
like an extreme example but in many
countries in Europe in France but in
Portugal too
there are definitely attacks on the
right to abortion so it's a struggle
which affects all of us it's it needs to
be continued and widened and we all need
to show solidarity with one another
but
women's rights are more than just the
right to abortion of course and there's
another kind of concern or other kinds
of concerns that we have
in the 20th century women's rights
movement
achieved an enormous amount as far as
rights were concerned access to
education
the right to contraception and Universal
Health Care women were able to enter the
labor market and Carry Out scientific
research
where today in Portugal at least
they occupy one of the most important
figures both in Research Laboratories
and universities they've shown women
have shown tremendous skill when it
comes to carrying out research and
overcoming the difficulties
with working in a country that used to
lag behind that was poor that had lots
of difficulties and it was difficult for
women to get a proper education at
school but the Portugal that we are
celebrating today the revolution that
we're celebrating today is something
that
was
brought about through the efforts of
women not just in the struggle against
fascism and oppression but also for
women fighting for their own dignity
these were difficult things to achieve
but they underpin women's struggle and
today we need to recognize that they are
problems here the issue we're talking
about this afternoon is the backlash
against women's rights we should mention
some advances too but we are unquestably
living in a period where women's rights
in many areas are going backwards
policy that calls itself egalitarian
needs to look at stability in jobs that
women have on the agenda in Portugal
that ah problems there are things going
backwards because of the huge increase
in the cost of living
the
the crumbling of the Health Service in
Portugal the lack of services and human
staff in the public services are a lack
of shortage of an expensive more
expensive Services as telecommunications
and transport these are all issues which
we face every day and it's
something where we keep fighting because
we can't have
equality without having the same
conditions for a dignified life for all
citizens
and our struggle in my movement and
women in general we want to see for
example salaries or women's salaries in
Portugal are among the lowest in Europe
that's an important Point therefore
Dean
national minimum wage wage in Portuguese
is 770
euros
and that's the level at which most women
earn would also want to see
increasing
recognition of women as teachers as
nurses being involved in business in
hotels these are all sectors which don't
really have much of a career path
there's not much of a possibility for
promotion
there's also a glass ceiling problem and
we want to just give women the dignity
which they deserve the lack of public
investment which of course has had an
impact and will continue to shape
women's whole lives
some of the worst affected sectors
social sector hotels health education in
textual industry
shoe making industry this is where women
earn far less than men
and
this is where you most see the disease
which is affecting us today which is the
precarious nature of work women don't
have stable jobs which they can be
confident about they are walking a
tightrope and are frightened of losing
their job every single day so women are
trying in Portugal to resist to protect
their rights and they're demonstrating
in the streets
and making all of these claims and we
want to contribute we have contributed
because you shouldn't forget
that women's profile
in store history art literature has
increased but
there's a tendency now to hide women and
women not to be as bold as they ought to
be when they're making their demands so
the international women's day is a
hugely important day for us it's not a
holiday a celebration it's something
that brings women together and there's
they can ask them these questions of
each other and talk to issues about each
other it's very important for us it's
one of the most important days for women
celebrated in Port Chloe and Lisbon it
talks about improving the women's living
conditions that's vitally important if
their rights are going to have any
meaning we have a brilliant wonderful
Constitution which talks about equality
the right to maternity paternity leave
the right of
non-discrimination equal pay for equal
work
but there are still
issues about Portugal going backwards we
can see Portia going backwards in many
of these areas Mr chairman there's also
the question of birth rates Portugal is
one of the countries where Berta is
extremely low and this of course has to
do with living conditions has to do with
demography we're concerned about that
it's also got to do with the question of
sexual and reproductive health
and this is something that should be
part of our concerns finally
since I don't have much time
we
believe at the moment
that it's time to
work
to realize that we're in a difficult
dangerous time
and that we need to keep
working with other women to keep linking
up with other women in the history of
democracy has this as its very raison
data we need to be united we need to be
together so that peace can win out so
that we can talk so that people sit down
at the same negotiation table even with
huge
differences we know what it's like as
women to sit down together and solve
problems so it's good that we have
things like this forums where we can
talk rather than trying to solve our
problems with weapons
and
the
arms race we can read in the paper is
increasing enormous amounts of money are
spent on weapons we
should remember there's no gender
equality there's no
equality when it comes to ethnic issues
or sexual orientation
and the
discrimination against women whether
they be Roma black white
needs to end and weapons aren't the way
to do it our weapon is peace and our
Unity a Unity working for women Polish
women and all women in Europe thank you
very much thank you very much thank you
very much Miss Marcus
you are speaking so beautifully that's
15 minutes went so fast
with you your real clinical
psychologists I can I could hear that
thank you very much for your kind words
and calling for solidarity and
cooperation we very much need this
solidarity and I say it also from the
country of historical solidarity so the
Poland solidarity means a lot
uh maybe not in practice unfortunately
okay we go to our last speaker Francesca
Sanders uh she's the senior policy
officer in transgender Europe embracing
all the diversity
and she is connected with us
remotely and yeah I see her okay there
she is
the floor is your Francesca welcome
thank you thanks very much good
afternoon my name is Francesca Sanders
I'm a senior policy officer at
transgender Europe TDU is a
membership-based organization with over
200 member organizations in 48 countries
in Europe and Central Asia including 26
in the EU our objective is to strengthen
the rights and well-being of the trans
community in the region and advocate for
securing our rights
honored to have been invited to this
hearing today on the backlash against
women women's rights as it is a serious
issue of concern for the trans Community
rightly any discussion on this issue
should include trans people because
trans people specifically trans women
are currently the subject of a vicious
and coordinated attack the challenges
their very existence and identities
trans people are being heavily targeted
by conservative political actors
religious groups and gender critical
feminists the same forces fighting
against sexual and reproductive Health
that we have heard about already today
and the effect is visible in rollbacks
to law and policy as well as the
increased rhetoric that opposes
protecting the rights of trans women
so what is the impact that we're seeing
across Europe legal gender recognition
based on self-determination which is the
internationally accepted idea that a
trans person has a right to change their
name and their gender marker on their
official documents without any
third-party test medical diagnosis or
Arbiter is under threat from gender
critical feminists and other right-wing
actors we saw this in Scotland where
there was intense pressure to block the
legal gender recognition reform as well
as in Spain and recently Germany just
this month Slovakia introduced a
proposal to outright ban legal gender
recognition in the same way that Hungary
did in 2021
we also see opposition to trans women
being accepted and placed in women's
segregated spaces like prisons and
shelters these are spaces where trans
women are particularly at risk of
violence abuse and harassment and in
fact need to be specifically protected
we know also from National statistics
and from reports from our members that
anti-trans harassment hate speech and
violence against trans people has
increased across the region this has
taken the form of hate speech from
political actors online doxing and
physical attacks
our members in Bulgaria and Romania for
example had their premises vandalized
and staff attacked in one case by a
presidential candidate and Associates
so what is this opposition and what kind
of narratives are we hearing about trans
people especially trans women
the dominant narrative employed is that
recognizing trans rights and the right
to self-determination of gender
dismantles the objective reality of sex
and destroys the heteronormative family
structure
gender critical feminists also argue
that is motivated by misogyny Francesca
I'm sorry to intervene but I was
informed by interpreters who are asking
to slow down so I'll give you enough of
time so just take your time speak slower
so the interpreters can interpret you in
the all languages of the world thank you
okay absolutely thank you for that
okay so gender critical feminists are
arguing that this is that
self-determination of gender is
motivated by misogyny and negates the
discrimination and violence faced by CIS
women who are consequently invisibilized
in law and policy
the second strand of argumentation is
that trans women are a danger to women
segregated spaces
which relies on the false narrative that
trans women as an entire category are
predators
it is understandable that one might find
these claims convincing after all we all
want to ensure our physical and
emotional safety and well-being
tgu has three main responses to these
arguments
first
rights are not a limited resource but
are the fundamental entitlements of a
person simply because they are human
securing the rights of trans women does
not take away CIS women's rights
while a balancing of Rights might be
needed in some cases there cannot be a
reason to diminish or roll back the
fundamental rights of trans people or
anyone for that matter
we need to work together to arrive at
solutions that work for all rather than
attacking trans women
whose physical safety emotional and
mental well-being and socioeconomic
security is already precarious
second
the concept of gender is not new
the feminist movement has built strong
arguments around gender-based
discrimination gender-based violence
and gender stereotyping that has helped
Advance many important legal and policy
reforms
and has also helped deepen our
understanding of how patriarchy Works to
oppress women and people of diverse
gender identities and sexualities
these Concepts have been accepted and
applied by international human rights
bodies such as the U.N cedor committee
U.N working group on discrimination
against women and girls
the office of the High Commissioner of
human rights at the UN
and the European court of justice
the Istanbul convention and the European
Court of Human Rights also recognizes
the right against discrimination based
on gender identity
trans people firmly Place their human
rights within this umbrella of rights
based on gender and gender identity
third as I have mentioned
trans people routinely face violence
discrimination and harassment
according to the 2019 lgbti survey of
the EU fundamental rights agency 36
percent of trans women and 33 percent of
trans men said that they had experienced
physical or sexual violence in the
preceding five years
tdu's 2022 transmodern monitoring data
showed that 95 of all reported murders
of trans people were of trans women
other exclusion axes such as ethnicity
migration status
sex work status age and disability
further exacerbates the violence and
discrimination experienced by trans
women
claims that trans women are perpetrators
of violence against CIS women are
inflated and anecdotal at best and
encourages fear-mongering
more importantly it is a distraction
from what should be our Collective goal
to demand better protections more safety
and opportunities
for CIS women and trans people alike
the forces that oppose trans rights are
the same forces which oppose CIS women's
true and complete equality
says women's rights over their bodies
and lives and CIS women's decisional
autonomy
I'd like to close my remarks today with
a reminder that trans movements are a
feminist struggle
trans people by their very existence
challenge existing societal Norms around
gender expression gender-based
stereotypes
and control over their own bodies
these are precisely the things that the
feminist movement challenges
the fight for Trans rights is a fight
for a feminist vision of the world and a
fight to dismantle patriarchy
in order for us to truly oppose the
forces that seek to limit the rights of
all women and trans people
we must recognize this and stand strong
together
we must be able to recognize and take
apart narratives that are couched as
supportive of trans people but in
reality are opposed to the existence of
trans people especially trans women
and as ospiet articulated very well and
I wanted to thank you for your excellent
intervention attacking trans people
and women's rights are just the
beginning
the ultimate goals dismantling democracy
itself
I'd like to once again thank you for
including the voices of the trans
community in this important discussion
today
and mentioned that TDU is available and
very willing to work with and support
the fund Committee in its efforts to
secure the rights of all women
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much Miss Sanders and we
really appreciate the expertise of
transgender Europe and your commitment
to our common fight against this
backlash on women's
rights including trans women and I just
want to inform you because you have
mentioned the Istanbul convention that I
had some good news for you this house
has today the joint committee is Libya
and fam committee decided to support EU
accession to Istanbul convention so we
are on good path on that as way that
this will be a first standard on that
and with this we go into the Q a session
and first of my list is a woman who is a
strong Fighter for women's rights and
she is also a reporter on our directive
proposal on the
directly dedicated to combating
gender-based violence Francis Fitzgerald
Francis the floor is yours EPP
thank you Robert and well done on
organizing today I think it's been very
informative for all of us and important
to have a session on the backlash
against women's rights because we hear
about it all the time but I think
there's nothing like hearing you know
the individual examples which we've
heard here today and I would like to
thank all four presenters for your you
know very strong presentation of the
issues as you see them I think it's been
very important for all of us to hear
what you've had to say and Justina I can
only agree with Robert how very moving
was your presentation and it brought me
back to Ireland really to Savita
halapovanova who died in slightly
different circumstances but nevertheless
the issue was the same and who was
really very influential in ensuring
because of that personal story that she
died because
she was miscarrying but there was still
a heartbeat and she wasn't saved and it
influenced our votes because between
1980 and 2018 170
000 Irish women traveled to the UK so I
suppose listening to what strikes me
that we're all very aware of in this
committee is that you cannot take the
progress in women's rights for granted
that we see you know progress and then
we see a backlash and really it's about
monitoring and continuing to work all of
the time on the Democratic principles we
all believe in and the values that the
European unionist exposes and on
equality so I think the kind of work
we're doing here in the committee and
monitoring and really being very alert
to both new
um new uh discriminations as well as
some of the old ones that go on is is so
important and to hear from the other
speakers as well about preserving
democracy really is core here as well
and I don't have a lot of questions I I
felt honored to listen to each of you
actually but perhaps I'd ask Justin and
Elizabeth
about the experience of Ukrainian women
who may be traveling into Poland who
have been assaulted who have been raped
and how you feel what is the response to
them in Poland and what can we do to
help in that particular circumstance as
well but certainly I mean the message I
take is the you know to be ever alert to
progress on women's rights and it's very
easy to see it being reversed and I
suppose we have the benefit of working
across Europe and being alert to the
changes that we see but you can't take
it for granted at all even when you've
had the legal changes that it starts you
know going in the opposite direction
again but thank you very all of you very
much for your presentation thank you
thank you Francis and the next one
representing snds Karina also from
Sweden
thank you sir
to continue in Swedish
many many thanks to all the speakers
who've spoken to us this afternoon
there is a a very serious situation
being faced by women's rights we've seen
that in the world in the EU in my own
country uh Sweden sometimes a drastic
legislation reduce our rights or
sometimes it's just step by step a
gradual degradation developments in
Poland is a good example of a
degradation of women's rights and the
statement we've heard from Poland today
is certainly tragic and very sad
women used to go from Sweden to Poland
to get to abortions and now it's
probably going to be the other way
around if that's at all possible so we
have also been questioning uh
equal opportunities a policy in Sweden
since the new government has been in
place we've seen a gradual
degradation of women's rights we were
very proud of our equal rights policies
but they've been shifted aside with the
new government we think it's going to
take 300 years to
get back to previous levels we can't
wait that long we know that conservative
and right-wing powers are constantly
constantly eroding away at our women's
rights we know that
anti-democratic movements are
well-funded and we know that the women's
movement is extremely strong as well so
we can find strength in that and we we
refuse uh to be downtrodden we've seen
that from protests in Iran uh in Poland
in the USA and these are just a few
examples and we see that it's difficult
sometimes to protest in certain
countries I mean Afghanistan for example
where girls over the age of 12 can't
even go to school and then there are
issues such as pay and violence
particularly in Conflict zones where
women are being used as a weapon and I
would like to ask what do you think that
we should do as European politicians in
the European Parliament
and we go to Netherlands now and renew
group Samira Rafaela
yes thank you very much chair and um
thank you for being here with us again
um I realized that it's definitely not
easy for you
to constantly fight this battle
but you know that you are extremely
supported by us and uh you are a true
hero because it is extremely Brave what
you're doing and we understand and we
realize the the efforts but also the
risks that you take personally
um to continue fighting this battle so I
would like to thank you for that very
much and of course you can always count
on the most possible support that we are
willing to give to you
so when speaking about the backlash
of women's rights in Europe then I think
for me as being part of a new generation
in Europe
this is extremely disappointing
um I've been looking at generations of
women also sitting in this room
who have been fighting so hard to get
the basic fundamental rights of women
and when sometimes looking at the
situation now I am wondering and asking
myself
I just hope that all the efforts that
they have put in this battle that's
it was worth it and that it has not been
for nothing and I think a new generation
of women
um are feeling exactly the same emotion
and this is exactly why we need to put
all the efforts and means into this
battle to make sure that we do not have
the backlash that we are so afraid of
um just today I organized a discussion
about the dangerous transnational
anti-gender movements that are leading
this backlash that are being supported
from also outside Europe there is a lot
of foreign interference a lot of foreign
influence there is a coordinate
coordinated
well-organized and well-financed
strategy Behind These anti-gender
movements take for example the agenda
Europe strategy and they are very
strategic they are really on point when
it comes to conducting their strategy so
that means that we also in this European
Parliament need to be aware of the
forces and the influences that we see in
our parliaments that we see here in the
European Parliament so for the upcoming
time we need to closely Monitor and
evaluate where the foreign influence is
going what the anti-gender movements are
doing where they get the power from and
where they get the strength from because
this is exactly what we need to
dismantle
and the kind of narratives that they use
are also about the same values that we
stand for
so we also need to be aware of the
extreme manipulation that they use
during the debates that we have the
conversation conversations that they
have and the narratives that they put
out there
so I hope that for the upcoming time
together with my colleagues here in the
European Parliament we can really
analyze closely where we can dismantle
these anti-gender movements I hope that
the European Parliament will decide that
some of these anti-gender movements
should not be allowed here in this
Parliament we should not accept that
narrative we should not accept the way
they think about human beings whether
it's about the lgbti community whether
it's about women whether it's about
trans people we cannot allow them to be
part
or to participate within Democratic
institutions
that need to fight and protect the
fundamental rights of our citizens
so I hope that we can strongly take that
responsibility together and just know
I'm expressing it again we will keep
supporting you we stay behind you we
stay next to you and we will make sure
that our voices are strongly heard
thank you
thank you very much thank you Val and
now we go to Spain to Margarita de la
Pizza carrion our colleague from ECR
and
thank you chairman thank you to our
guests yes there's
a question of visibility of women we
have the committee on women's rights but
we need to be more visible there's a
lack of plurality of opinions it's an
incomplete uh picture and of course we
need to address the issue of abortion
talking about uh women's rights and
focusing on abortion perhaps
disregards the broad palette of issues
facing Society for example a woman uh
uh
in it with an unwanted pregnancy uh
can be in a moment of great distress
I've uh I've been on the phone with
people who've discovered their pregnancy
and sometimes
there's been so much pressure
to have an abortion and the pressure
comes from their partner
and
it might also come from there
the parents and many of these women have
been abused or raped and
the attacker doesn't want to be burdened
with uh
a pregnancy the social uh
services
also bring pressure to bear in this case
I was faced with a woman in difficulties
being
pressured to carry out an abortion
because the child didn't meet
the so-called normal standards so I'm
sure that you must be concerned all of
you must be concerned about these
situations too where a woman is
is pressured to have an abortion surely
you're concerned about that as well
because that happens a lot
I mean you always talk about the
difficulty in having access to an
abortion but
what about uh a woman who does want to
continue with her pregnancy and if this
is happening because
abortion has become
normal and women are being forced to go
ahead with the abortion simply because
the pregnancy didn't arrive at the right
time for the right person
I mean imagine uh our mothers when we
were conceived many of us would not be
here
if we'd had the the standards that we
have today
remember
the practice the development of the
practice of abortion first of all it was
for specific reasons now it's just based
on the will of the woman the European
Parliament
supports abortion without any time limit
many would not
do that
on would not carry out an abortion on
the day of delivery imagine that these
are things to think about I encourage
you to think about these things I'm a
pharmacist nobody wants an abortion we
all agree nobody wants to be exposed to
these procedures
I mean we always talk about safe
abortions as if women had no other
recourse than than abortion but the who
proposed the
procedure needs medical assistance I
mean exposing a woman to this treatment
without medical supervision can put her
life at risk because if the woman
doesn't know at what stage of the
pregnancy she's in she could be in a
very compromised a situation it can even
be fatal
the the abortion is not always the
solution what we need to do is get the
get the give the woman support it's
normal to feel confused we should help
that woman
to live through the the pregnancy she
might not know what she wants but how
many uh how many women thought they
didn't want to be pregnant and then
change their mind along the way how many
mothers uh
started off by thinking they didn't want
to be pregnant
I would like this to debate to be really
about women's rights
an authentic debate on the rights of
women in society I don't want it to be
limited to the practice of abortion
because there are so many other
important things to talk about thank you
thank you Margarita and before we
continue with the speakers
I just want to remind you that you're
not you're not being limited with your
freedom of taking the floor you speak
double the time you had and I did not
intervene
the decision on the composition of this
meeting was made by the coordinators
which you participate in personally and
you also participated in our last
mission to Poland and you could take
floor at every meeting and I heard that
you were very active
so
please do not accuse me as a chair for
any censorship of this committee because
this is not the case and I gave you some
examples thank you very much we continue
with
our colleagues
then I have Fred matich who is famous of
his report the Matic report on sexual
and reproductive health and rights so
Fred the floor is yours thank you
thank you Robert and thanks to all the
colleagues who spoke today and presented
their experience
we hear you and we understand loud and
clear I believe you also know that this
committee now under the Robert
leadership and previously under the
leadership of our colleague Evelyn has
approached this issue very seriously and
dealt with it on the numerous occasions
there is no doubt that we are facing a
powerful moment movement
that is well organized and financed and
that their only goal to return us to the
dark Medieval ages I have already spoken
on this topic many times and I want to
emphasize once again in me in most of us
here in the committee you have allies
and there is no doubt that together you
will always stand in defense of women's
rights I would like to ask our experts
Justina already mentioned something but
tell us again
What specifically can we do that we
haven't done yet how can we help in
political or the other way prevent this
regressive agenda from the achieving git
goals and how can we directly help you
in what
you do on the ground for the protection
and safety of the for all women and
girls thank you
thank you very much Fred and then I have
our vice chair Radka maxova from Czech
Republic the third floor is yours
Roberta
um
thank you Robert I want to thank all the
speakers I want to thank eustina for
very uh Vivid description of the horror
story which luckily had a happy ending
the health of a perhaps a future mother
with a better partner was preserved
personally this story has affected me
because I have experience with this
and I fear that the Czech Republic might
embark on the path
um like in like in Poland because the
minister of Labor is a Christian
Democrat who is receiving advice from
anti-democratic movements that influence
him
as a commissioner Delhi said and
at our last committee meeting now we
have to focus on protecting what we have
achieved the rights that we have
acquired
although I consider the European
Parliament to be very open and
Progressive and I want to thank them we
managed to pass paid transparency
um
gap of
directive and women in
supervisory boards we still have to
focus on protecting what we have we have
to
recognize right for safe abortion as a
basic human right and it should be
embedded in the charter of human rights
of the EU it is not easy but in my view
it is the only way uh to protect women
and give them free choice
apart from what we are doing
invite calling on governments and
pointing out human rights abuses now how
to pressure the governments to update uh
or amend their legislation to ensure
free access to Safe abortion so that
women's health is not put it put under
threat and that we can protect girls in
the future as well
Munoz
thank you chair and thank you very much
for the different presentations showing
us how important is a non-androcentric
knowledge to achieve gender equality and
also to combat uh gender backlash gender
backlash that is really traumatic really
very dramatic in in Poland I really
appreciate your sincerity and your
presentation but I think you should be
considered Beyond Poland and it should
be considered an attack to our
democracies we should include really in
the core European data fans of the core
European values because if we see the
countries in which it is
more evident there is a clear
relationship in between the erosion of
the democracies and the rule of law and
the the harm to to women's rights
um that could happen in any country at
least and uh in part as it had been say
but a few of us it is because there is
this International anti-gender and
anti-feminist movement that is very well
organized very well financed and with
very clever and concrete strategy I mean
this movement should not be understood
as a group of fundamentalists who want
to stop abortions but as different
movements are sometimes very different
from each other and within a very
sophisticated
Global phenomenon at the service of our
reactionary agenda that uses this regard
of women's rights and LG TV rights of
the center of its political action that
is they use the anti-women agenda as a
tool to get power and to achieve what
they propose which goes often Beyond
um the legalization of of abortion so it
is very clear for me that they they are
acting United even if sometimes they
don't collude in many things but they
are acting very clever United my
question is is once again
how could really work together because
now there is a lot of
divisions and differences within a
feminist movement and women's movement
but they are even if they are different
they are united in front of us
so how could really work together that
we put really feminism and the defense
of of women and gender equality at the
core of the defense of our democracies
in order also to have more people to
back Us in this fight for gender
equality thank you very much
honorable
no we go to Italy in the person of
Moretti thanks very much chairman on the
subject of Italy
finally
a few days ago the green light was given
for free distribution of the pill to
women and that's when there's a
right-wing government in Italy which is
doing all it can to turn back the clock
and bring everybody backwards it's a
real Revolution this as far as women's
health is concerned and their right to
decide what they do with their own
bodies and they can decide whether they
do wish to become mothers and in
particular when
they can do that we've talked about this
with colleagues in the Socialist groups
a big issue of
sex education in schools it means
educating young people to respect
themselves to respect each other to get
to know their own bodies and to protect
their own health and I think that Europe
needs to be doing a lot more in this
area it should start providing direct
Finance to schools so that they can
organize
courses dealing with sexuality and
sexual health
because only in that way through
teaching people that we can grow up a
generation of free men and women
fighting against the four or who will
stand out against the forces trying to
bring us back to Margarita de la Pisa
let me say something she talks about
repression but these pressures the only
are they just coming from one side or
are governance like the Polish
government
themselves exerting pressure when it
comes to women's rights to choose about
what happens with their own bodies one
pressure is perhaps more important than
the other as far as you're concerned but
Margarita are you all not in favor of
women's Freedom women's right to choose
who they are what they how they be what
they do with their own bodies if you
were to have a daughter of 14 years of
age who gets pregnant after suffering
sexual assault how would you help her
what would you do with that little girl
I think that what we need to do
is what you need to do is
get information because women especially
young women are no longer willing to let
someone else decide for them and what
happens with their bodies thank you
thank you
next speaker
is
Lucas kohout from Poland whose
co-reporter
ratification
on the question of ratification of the
Istanbul convention by the EU
congratulations once again it's a
tremendous success and I give you the
thought
thank you chairman upstairs
let me thank you
on in my own behalf but also behalf of
thousands of women you've demonstrated
that it's
worth trying to be oneself and to show
courage
the
next day pill doesn't kill anybody it's
a question of
dignity I live inside Asia 22 kilometers
from the border
the Czech border
and in bucklemen
you can find next day pills
in chemists
and these 22 kilometers
that I live away from the border to
border between two women two sorry Two
Worlds to ways of looking at women Czech
Republic has one of the highest birth
rates in Europe I don't think it's a
coincidence I'm very pleased to see that
two committees in the European
Parliament have voted in favor of the
possibility of the European Union being
a part of the
Istanbul convention I've been working
since the beginning of this Parliament
on this matter with Mrs kochari and
it thanks to the Swedish presidency
among other things
that we are against all the conservative
forces fighting against us being able to
bring this in so that there will be
access to
contraception that's self-evident for
nearly all the member states in the EU
it's something that's obvious 22
kilometers from my house but it needs to
be something that's available in all of
the European Union including Poland so
thanks very much
to uh guests do
remember the situation will one day
return to normal in Poland thank you
we'll cash once again congratulations to
you and Anika for your brilliant
achievements and with cross fingers
for ratification Miss Pisa carry on has
asked for the floor again if not I can
close the if no one else wants to speak
I'll give muggery to the floor for a
minute and a half and close the speakers
list
for the
questions or they were answered in what
I said before when abortion is up for
discussion when it's being normalized
you're basically obliging women to Avail
themselves of it
if there's anything unusual about the
pregnancy and that
the question is whether Society is
questioning whether women want to have a
baby if they're having a baby it's
because they want to and they can if
you're having a baby it's because you
can if you don't help a woman and
provide any help for a woman when she's
pregnant under difficult circumstances
she should only get pregnant when she
can allow herself to look after it so
just the existence of abortion is
somebody that works against the
interests of women because it
people take away the possibility of
helping her out
as for the what was asked about my
diet child of 14 if she were raped and
got pregnant
my help would be that she wouldn't get
raped in the first place the abortion
wouldn't solve the trauma that is
unfortunately being more and more common
in Europe
so the solution to rape is that there's
no rape not abortion is not the solution
abortion is another kind of aggression
against the woman
I would be with my daughter with all
possible tenderness I would help her to
become the mother how many people are
the result of rape and have happy lives
don't you get irritated because you
think it's more or less mandatory to
have an abortion after you've been raped
how many people today
there's lots of people who are the
result of rape and would actually be
offended by what the words that have
been spoken in this room that's a
colleague and now I give the floor to
our uh distinguished guests in the order
of uh
the speaking uh
order and I will say we used to have a
drinks you have each maximum three
minutes unfortunately because we need to
really conclude we already round out of
the time we really need to conclude soon
so you still not the floor is yours for
three minutes I will try it very fast uh
first of all I want to thank you for the
huge support to be honest this support
is much much bigger than I got from the
pollution piece so I feel here like
almost like at home and I really
appreciate this because this makes me
much much braver when I go to Country I
start to fight with the system and I
want to say about our work we trust
people
We Trust in decision of women
and we support every decision people
have
and
especially in my work in abortional
borders every day every day I speak with
100 people
and most what I hear is that they hide
abortions
[Music]
um
and and they do this in a secret then
they are forced to do it
so uh in if I hear that there is a
person who is forced to stop the
pregnancy I would protect this person as
much as I protect those who want to stop
the stop the pregnancy
about from the moment of the war has
started we started to count the people
uh who contact us those from the Ukraine
and in through this almost more than a
year uh we have
more than 100 500 people 100 or 500
people and uh as we the the the whole
the support is coming from the society
the same uh when the the Ukrainian
people came to the country uh the the
society just organized ourselves and the
same is with the access to abortion we
we help people no matter their
nationality uh we had the same way the
Ukrainian has how we said though those
who are on the Belarus border so we try
to
um to give the same information to every
person who is from Afghanistan who is
from Iran who is from Germany the the
students who are studying here in the
Poland uh and need our access to
abortion but what we do more to help the
Ukrainian people our partner women help
women organizations send to the to uh
the war zone around 400 000 packages of
uh abortion pills uh and also I don't
remember the numbers of emergency
contraceptive pill to help those who who
stay in the country and have to have the
access to abortion pills in a situation
that when there is no access
and
what what
maybe I I want to to repeat this but and
to to be this and phrased again what we
would like to have from the from the
European Parliament first of all is to
push the pressure for the Polish
government for the decriminalization of
those who help in abortion actually like
because it's not only activists who can
be criminalized there could be also
mothers who have daughters and partners
and friend to friend there could be
anyone and first to support financially
abortion that board is because we do the
job we really help people to to get
access and to pay for their abortion and
I think the good step will be this this
chapter of
and the women's rights and it is a good
start to decrease the differences
between uh European countries with this
uh these rights thank you
thank you very much
deserved upload
thank you very much uh eustina and now
we go to uh beta Coral took who is as I
said remotely from Poland or Sweden
from Poland this time saying hello to
Poland then yes everyone is yours yes
thank you very much there are many
questions about what to do obvious for
me is to that we need to first of all
spread information and knowledge about
what anti-gender campaigns are about
what are the goals and what are the
effects of those campaigns and I'm very
happy that many of the speakers and MPS
have discussed the international
connections the origins and the finances
that are behind the anti-gender
campaigns uh so I think that this
knowledge has to be promoted and has to
be implemented and integrated within the
policy making processes another issue
what I've been saying is why I have been
focusing so much on knowledge production
and expertise is because I think that
especially within uh modern sort of
policy making procedures the type of
knowledge we have the type of
um
truths that are being circulated and
produced are of key importance that's
why we have to have more Finance more
money for uh research on these issues
and I'm currently part of a Kindle
project which is financed by Horizon
2020 21 uh scheme and I think that we
really need more this kind of schemes
which look at the connection between uh
women's rights minority rights and the
quality of democracy because this is key
here and also we need to not hesitate to
withdraw financial support for groups
which promote language and facilitate
discrimination and violence because as I
said very often these groups claim that
they are working on behalf of women's
rights or minority rights but when you
look at the effects you actually see the
increase of violence and my last point
is to
um miscarrian and I have been involved
in activism on behalf of single mothers
in Poland for over a decade now so it's
glister clear for me that the mother's
rights are a part of feminist agenda but
what you have been describing the
situation when women is pressured into
making a decision whatever this decision
is is actually violence it's domestic
violence or partnership the violence
and this is exactly why we need because
this violence happens we this is why we
need to implement uh for example
Istanbul convention to really protect
women from violence so the answer to
your question is we need to protect
women from violence and not take away
their right to decide about their future
and their bodies thank you very much
thank you very much professor and the
next speaker is Miss Regina Marcus
celebrating their national holiday
congratulations once again and the floor
is yours for three minutes
together
thank you very much
let me start by flagging up this issue
that rights are indivisible they're
indissociable so you can't speak about
women's rights
without talking about the right to work
the right to education and sexual
Reproductive Rights
neither no of one of these rights is
more important than any of the others
obviously at the moment we're giving
priority to some of these issues
which
in Europe
we should recognize
there are countries where things are
getting worse we should recognize that
where women are
having fewer rights and there are
studies that show that when it comes to
sexual Reproductive Rights
those women who have fewest options to
be helped are the poorest and today
there are countries in Latin America
where it's also women are criminalized
and actually jailed for seeking
abortions
there are situations as well
where support centers in France for
example
are being closed down
so there is a movement
backwards
and that's given rise to some of these
tragic situations we've heard about
today we had that in the past in
Portugal too and as I've said
after the law in Portugal the abortion
law
it wasn't that women are afraid to have
an abortion whenever they want this is
what people say to try to muddy the
waters in Portugal for example it's 10
weeks there's a 10-week limit you have
to have it in the first 10 weeks
it's not that oh I feel like having an
abortion today no it's not like that at
all we should be careful when if if
you're against abortion to try to spread
ideas like that
because there are lots of reasons why
women ask for an abortion in Portugal
the majority re were poor women
Studies have been carried out
where women who have
tried to inject themselves or drinks or
water
with
complications which are absolutely
terrible and these are the poor women
it's well known
the hospital beds are fill filled with
people carrying out abortions themselves
under terrible conditions that's
finished now in Portugal that doesn't
happen anymore we have moved back in
certain areas but
we've got the morning after pill now
we've got
the
less invasive versions of abortion
Medical Services can
help simplify the process make it less
expensive makes it make it less
bureaucratic because this new medical
system is
doesn't it require some surgical
intervention so that's what we want for
women just to be able to choose we're
aware
the the 10-week limit in Portugal isn't
the same as in France as things aren't
done
the same in other countries so we need
as women to be aware that we're not
asking for legislation
that if someone has a pregnancy they
don't like
and they just get just getting abortion
the question of rape and partners
[Music]
the idea that they might not want to
stay pregnant because of financial
problems
so why don't we just put women in the
focus here it's a political option
therefore if poverty is the problem
so
what we want what we're speaking in
favor of is that women should be able to
decide within a legal framework in this
legal framework should be put together
democratically in a parliament obviously
we are trying to exert pressure so that
we get the best law possible and that it
provides a measure of social justice
because it's the poorest women as I've
said who have most recourse
and I can
understand
lots of women in the past went to
Britain to get their abortions in the
past because it was they were wealthy
enough to be able to afford to go other
people had to try and just make do buy
some of the methods I've ingesting salt
Etc at home
so
lots of
women as I said should be able to have
sex education at school should have
access to family planning
now
things have changed because from the
moment that they
they announce if they go to a doctor to
talk about
families planning they immediately get
access to contraception but it's more to
women's rights than this you need in the
European Parliament I believe to have
public health policies labor policies to
have equal pay for equal work
all of this needs to be done
so that women's rights as a whole are
respected and women are treated with
dignity because we can't go back
I know it's your holiday and I know it's
important day for you but I really need
to stop you now I'm sorry do you want to
say the final word the final word go on
I just like to thank you once again Mr
chairman so we can't
these we need to be more complex in our
nurses we can't just simplify the
problems as if one thing and the last
speaker and please keep your time
Francesca Sanders from transgender eel
thank you I will be quick
um I wanted to say thank you very much
for all of the comments and words of
support it's really heartening to know
that we have so many allies in this
space and elsewhere and also that you're
so deeply aware of the issues and how
interconnected and well coordinated
these actors are
um the the anti-trans and anti-gender
voices are very loud and so it's really
helpful to also hear the supportive
voices
um I wanted to quickly answer the
question about what can we do that we
haven't done yet and I have two things
to mention one is about building
alliances across movements this is
something that we talk about a lot but
we haven't really achieved it yet so
bringing different actors together
um recognizing that these attacks are
they start with minority groups they
start with sexual health and other
issues
um but their ultimate goal is much
deeper than that and it's a common
tactic of the anti-gender movement to
divide and conquer and to pit us against
each other and say for example women's
rights are in uh conflict with trans
rights and that giving trans rights
somehow affects other women's rights but
as someone else mentioned rights are not
uh it doesn't work like that rights are
not like pie
um more rights for one group are in fact
more rights for everyone
um and the anti-gender movement is very
coordinated and very organized and so we
also need to be and the second
suggestion is to Echo um what else
better said about further research
um also about understanding people's
values and where people are coming from
and what can what moves people there is
there's a large segment of the
population who don't fully understand
the issues perhaps they've never met
someone who needed an abortion they've
never met a trans person
um and they they perhaps don't
understand what the issues are and we
need to work with them and really inform
people what the issues are and what the
risks are and that's everything thank
you
thank you very much Miss Sanders and
thank you very much to all of the
speakers and it was extremely
interesting discussion and I just want
to assure you that we will monitor the
situation we heard your voices we took
your tips for further actions of
European Union including this house and
we understand and we see that
you cannot take women's rights for
granted as Francis has said and many of
you has said and it's like a beautiful
flower you need to water it every day
not to
let it fade away and that's why it's our
common obligation and I just want to
assure you you will again you will never
walk alone and we believe this in the
context of women and the backlash we
need to stand in solidarity he and we
will because it's their body their life
and it should be their choice no one's
else thank you very much for being here
today once again to all of you and with
this I end up the committee meetings
which we start at nine in the morning
and we just finished so thank you my
colleagues for being with us thank you
to interpreter Secretariat advisors
administrations and the guests
especially thank you very much
thanks
so now
I want to ask all the people to who are
not authorized to leave the room because
the